so this talk today will be for some
people it'll be an introduction to
trying to look at some statistics of
deep neural networks for others this may
be more interesting in terms of seeing
how do you develop kind of a research
strategy for approaching a challenge
like this so but I guess before we start
can I ask who here is trained already a
deep neural network yeah okay almost
everyone and who here's worked with PI
torch or at least got some experience
with it
nice okay about half so we'll try to
have something new I think the statistic
is probably new for most people that try
to keep it all so general sure lots of
pictures so you have kind of more an
impression and hopefully if you have
questions we can talk about that
afterwards so about me my name is Justin
shank and I'm a PhD candidate at Radford
University and Nijmegen Netherlands I'm
also a research engineer at Pelt Ariane
based in Stockholm Sweden and my
background is in neuroscience research
from Texas us so quite international
already and the results here were
developed during research at Austin
Brook University in Germany and also
with BOTS Ariane so what veteran builds
and what I'm worried I work on with them
is it's a deep neural network model
builder and so if you for example wanted
to build the deep neural network and you
wanted to be able to do it in a
graphical interface and have sharing
your models version controls to
deployment all that it's really nice so
that's that's kind of the background an
application of that for that a similar
model that is deep emotion dot IO which
you can drag a video to this to the page
and you get the emotions the facial
expressions recognize from frames so
that's one application you could check
out that uses that same technology and
I'm also part of the Intel software
innovator program which does early
prototyping for
for until hardware and software like the
Nvidia video compute stick so I'll
introduce some motivation so what makes
the challenge of improving the neural
network topology interesting and I'll
introduce the convolutional auto encoder
because that's the base model that I've
been that I was using in this research
I'll also motivate why using a PI torch
implementation rather than tensorflow
and/or any other framework also some
visualizations of these pre activations
that that are used for I understand the
statistic here and then I'll give the
kind of the final results for the layer
saturation this is this metric that's
used to determine how over parameters
are under parameterize your layer is
because you want to get really high test
accuracy but you also want to understand
the dynamics of your network and if we
have time we'll we can go through
questions so the motivation starts with
if you start building a deep neural
networks and you're doing it to say
you're doing it from scratch or you're
starting with the template some idea of
where to start there's always one
question that pops up is how many how
many units do I need in any given hidden
layer so so if it's a dense layer why do
I have ten ten hundred and or thirty-two
where does this number come from and it
seems kind of magical it's like it's
pulled out of air or someone figured it
out maybe empirically they found out
this is the best for this given model on
this given layer as soon as you start
experimenting you you want to have more
insight into where does this number come
from or where what is guiding this
process other than test accuracy so not
only do we want to understand this
number but we also want to improve our
models we want to optimize them not just
for test accuracy but also for training
time an example of when that's necessary
is we have this model that was built to
Pelt arjan for predicting weather and it
uses a convolutional lsdm with an auto
encoder to reduce
this high dimensional satellite data
into a 2000 unit bottleneck and that
2000 unit bottleneck isn't pushed on to
an elf's TM but why 2000 units why not
200 why not 20,000 so understanding the
practical constraints there is necessary
when you're optimizing them the network
also for innovating it's useful to have
some insight into the statistics like
why like what is happening when I change
this layer how does it affect the next
layer that's something that you don't
get out-of-the-box with any frameworks
so it's part of the motivation for
building delve so why so starting with
an autoencoder I chose an autoencoder is
the baseline model to do the test with
because for one we had the use case if
the path Arion with the weather
understanding whether they have an auto
coder that reduces the dimensions for
your input down to one vector but also
it's really simple to understand
theoretically it's mapping an input into
a reconstruction of the input so yeah
writing papers and so forth becomes a
little cleaner right so but then also we
have this nice bottleneck that can be
understood so anything that I say about
how do we reduce how do we understand
the number of units in a hidden layer so
a hidden layer and the bottleneck that
these using them interchangeably here
because it's the same effect and other
possible uses for auto-encoders then for
whether you can can touch on that
they're used for denoising for example
you could do you know as images or for
generative purposes so variational on
encoders and again if you're building a
generative auto encoder or generative
model and you want to know how many
units do I need in this layer this is
going to be a useful concept there as
well generally so convolutional encoder
is has that purpose of reducing the
inputs into a low dimensional
representation and the convolutional
part is where you convolve a griten
feature
here in gray over an image blue and you
gets a nice green feature map out so
that lets you detect certain patterns
like edges in the images yeah also when
you go from those feature maps in the
green so say you have one for each
Channel RGB then you want to push them
into a bottleneck you can just flatten
all of those feature maps and you get
two nice long bottleneck layer mmm
perhaps for added challenge to this task
I chose an inception v3 Network so what
they were using at Pelt Arjan before was
a VG network and Inception v3 was known
to have higher accuracy on image net
challenge it's very deep with 48 layers
and it introduces some some new tricks
here we're for example the one by one
convolution where you can take the
several channels and you can convolve
across those dimensions so say you have
RGB and you just kind of put a pole
right through them and send them up so
to write the input size that's required
for inception is 299 by 299 for my
experiments I used to see fart n which
if anyone's worked with that before the
the size is 32 by 32 so we had to up
sample and down sample to get to 299 by
299 so it's a bit overkill for the
purpose but easier to work with the data
and the motivation for choosing pi torch
was you get a lot of things you get
access to a lot of features with PI
torch that you wouldn't get directly
with other implementations tensorflow
has perhaps improve that with their
eager execution but first this specific
kind of metric it was super easy to pull
it out from a PI torch of model and I'll
show what that looks like let's let's
show them what that what that looks like
so the other tools that were useful in
trying to develop a statistic for layer
over parameterization were torch vision
which lets you load and see far tenday
out of the box again and I pie widgets
so if you're living in Jupiter notebook
environment and you want to visualize
your data and you don't want to send it
over to tensor board every time that you
want to you know inspect something it's
really useful if you have a quick
responsive API for something that lets
you visualize it and in this case it was
iPad widgets so what level are we
talking about in terms of the neural
network so if you're familiar with the
inputs and the activations and the
weights coming from each of the nodes
then you have what's called this P
activation state or latent
representation which then an activation
function is supplied to so your output
of the layers if it's going to be the
activations and before it gets
before you apply reloj or hyperbolic
tangents you have a pre activation state
and PI torch it's super easy to pull
that out because you can just apply your
fully convolutional layer on to like a
fully convolutional operator on the
layer and then you have a so in this
case a thousand dimensional tensor and
you can just add you convert it to numpy
hi first you have to put on the CPU if
you're using GPU and then convert to
numpy and then appended to a list within
your class or over your environment and
and that way you can get a list of those
vectors of the pre activations for free
for that specific layer and then you can
if in the auto encoder case you just
decode that directly so that's your code
how when you're decoding from in this
case of the inception our coder you have
again that code that long that long
vector and you want to reshape that and
if something looks like images so you're
going to reshape it into five by five
patches or it could be whichever
dimensions but can reshape it using the
view for a view method and then your
decoding occurs normally you can you can
have a totally reversed
like a symmetric auto-encoder where you
do everything from inception but then
reverse it but I don't recommend it with
inception in this case you can just
simplify that your life and do a few
transpose convolutions and and add a
dense layer to in there so that's how
the auto encoder is going to work if you
want to visualize things in this
environment with the jupiter notebook
and the eye widgets it's really nice
it's also makes really nice gifs or
gifts if you want to show what your
research is doing and how it's how like
how you can change parameters to modify
what the output is I can only recommend
it so like in this case I was looking
where does early stopping occur for
different models models with different
bottleneck sizes given certain
parameters for early stopping so
assuming that I have the patience and
the minimum delta fixed how did the
training look for those different models
so that was useful in this case and the
iPod widget usage is you can define any
arbitrary function and then call the if
I watch an interactive method and
include that function is an argument one
of the first things I was curious about
is is there a pattern and how the these
pre activation States and the
distribution of values in that per
activation state so again to give you
some intuition where we are we are in
the and the auto encoder case where at
the bottleneck and we've got a vector of
say ten or a hundred or a thousand units
and we want to know how many of them are
you know really large scalar values how
many of them are closer to zero and how
does that change over training so this
little widget was used - it was
developed to see the change over time
and in this case the the blue was the
early in the training and the Green was
later in the training so there was a
gradual broadening of the values so that
gave me some insight that there is a
change in the distribution of these
values over training is there some way
we can detect some kind of pattern to
indicate okay
your values are getting off center or
your values are you know there's some
kind of pattern that's occurring that
can suggest okay now it's time to hop
off the training or it's time to reduce
your the size of your lair so in in
terms of plotting so if we wanted to in
the X dimension here we have the
bottleneck layer size so as you increase
bottleneck lair size then your test loss
will decrease which makes sense so you
start off with 10 units and a bottleneck
in it's not enough so but as soon as you
you increase that to 16 or 32 you get
big jumps improvements in your test loss
but at some point you kind of plateau
right so there's not much difference in
this case between the 32 and the 64 so
how do you identify where that is how do
you identify that that's kind of the
main problem to solve is how do you how
do you know if further making your model
bigger is going to make any marginal
improvements and also considering the
amount of time it takes the Train so the
method that that I applied was back in
decomposition of this pre activation
matrix so again with the bottleneck you
take the history of those bottlenecks
over time then you make a covariance
matrix from that and then you can apply
aggie decomposition so with numpy it's
in P dot CoV and then n P Lin ouch
I can H and then you get the
eigenvectors and eigenvalues out so as
as a reminder of what that is your
eigenvalues and eigenvectors are the you
can think of it as the the directions
that are necessary to explain all of the
variance so your eigen eigen values or
your scalars that when multiplied by a
vector give you that matrix times that
vector so that's the terminology in the
background for that and then the
spectrum is just the set of the
eigenvalues so say you have you know ten
dimensions you'll have ten eigenvalues
and vectors you want to have the you
want to put all those eigen values into
set so I wanted to visualize these
changes these the directions of
activation and overtraining and see how
that changes so started plotting the
these are the eigenvalues for the first
the first eigen vectors and seeing how
that changes over training for different
for models with different size
bottlenecks and then also tried
normalizing that by itself that didn't
give me any insight but it made pretty
graphs so but the question then is maybe
we can figure out how many directions
are needed to explain 99% of the
variance so the motivation for referring
to 99% of the variance actually it comes
about from from another paper singular
vector canonical correlation analysis by
record at all and they're trying to
achieve a similar goal using a different
method you want to be able to find out
based on something like a pca principal
component analysis of the the
bottlenecks if you can figure out how
many directions or how many units the
goal is to get to the units how many
units are necessary to explain the
variance it's quite a jump actually but
it does give us some insight into the
train dynamics so by planning by
plotting different neural networks with
different over different times the
neural networks and this is the line
moving to the right
that's overtraining we were able to see
when does it require so many you know X
percent of so on the left it's it's the
ratio when does it require that X
percent of the of the eigenvectors to
explain 99% of the variance and that
would hopefully give us some insight
into when the layer has already been
saturated or when is it have space to be
filled so what I thought was maybe more
insightful and so promising but I won't
be able to continue this research at the
moment so
to take it over is looking at the phase
transitions so for example say you have
those eigenvalues and you have the first
here's the top three eigenvalues over
training by themself it doesn't tell you
much except that it's always increasing
generally increasing right but if you
look at the first derivative of it you
start to see dips and changes and if you
see the second derivative you see dips
and changes as well so there's perhaps a
reason to think that if you're trained
while your model is training if you get
data in it could be seen as something of
an anomaly for the model or that the
model is not that that that instance for
that batch coming in has a certain type
of effect on the layer with that
specific number of units so it'd be
interesting perhaps to do more
statistical analysis on that so another
tool that was used here to kind of
explain and show to people what I was
doing because you can only get so far
unless you can communicate your results
is making a nice interactive decoding in
the in the Jupiter notebook so with this
we're able to take any given bottleneck
sorry you're experimenting with several
different sized bottleneck auto-encoders
and you can decode it in the browser and
you're able to perturb eight the model
by changing the activation or the pre
activation states for any given unit
within that layer it's nice for seeing
if for example how sensitive a certain
model is to perturbations at specific
units and then around this time it
became pretty clear that you need to
visualize the actual activations over
training so taking the CFR ten dataset
which is ten categories of a horse frog
dog automobile and then see how over
time those different bottleneck and
beddings where do they go into a PCA
space and you see that it's that there's
quite a consistent trajectory in this
case the red is automobile that's a
consistent trajectory that they follow
and in three-dimensions there's even
more interesting kind of seahorse
structure here so it would be really
interesting to find out for example if
you could make this more efficient so
that that way it could all be mapped
into a single dimension right if you're
if you're doing PCA and you find that
you have kind of a circle or an arc then
you can apply linear PCA you can
straighten that out and try to reduce
the number of dimensions needed to
explain all the variance and again the
motivation is if we can explain the
variance of the activations for these
bottlenecks with less number of units
that would be good then we can say okay
here's a tip you know you reduce the
number of units you have in this layer
so this gives you some encouragement
that there is structure within these
this embedding space and there's
something we could do to kind of draw a
line between it and find that so so we
saw what decoding these embeddings
looked like what what are the embeddings
look like themselves and I mean they're
pretty noisy as you can guess but what's
kind of interesting is when you look
within class you do see certain patterns
I mean it makes sense that a model
trained to detect patterns for
automobile or or bird is going to see
those instances similarly but how
similar I mean is it similar to the
naked eye similar and you do see certain
consistent I mean it could be it's not
yet empirically validated but you see
some perhaps similar patterns and
activations for within class instances
so that's kind of kind of interesting
but yet it doesn't yet tell you how to
apply it after training the the the
activations were smoother more
consistent with in a more narrow range
so the jumping to the part where the
application is so from the research and
trying to put together the tools and
look for a method that gives you some
insight into the pattern the dynamics
next was building Delft and delve is a
pip lab Python library
that you can install tip install delve
and when you run it with the example in
this case the deep neural network there
is a simple one it will show you the
layer saturation which is the number of
units required to explain 99% of the
variance so of this pre activation
matrix so in this case if we have say
three three layers and we're modifying a
hidden layer and we want to see how does
it affect the adjacent layers and how
how does adjusting the size of that
layer affect the saturation of that
layer and of other layers in this case
we have hidden start with the hidden
layer size 8 and as it's a very small
number so you have high saturation in
this case looking at linear to
saturation is quite high as you increase
that layer size of 32 the linear to
layer decreases and what's also kind of
interesting is that the following layer
layer 3 increases at saturation so you
you have a compensatory increase as you
increase that make the layer longer then
it requires more requires more units to
account for all the variants ok
perhaps that's also more clear in this
case so here we have a 6 layer fully
connected Network doing a regression
task and we can see that as so what this
is showing is overtraining with three
different width models with three
different size layers in the linear one
space ok so as you increase from 10 to
100 to 300 you see that the first layer
linear 1 the saturation actually
decreases right so you increase the size
and decreases at the saturation and then
in the linear 2 layer you see a
compensatory increase so when the first
layer decreases saturation the second
layer increases so what kind of insight
does that give us it suggests that we
can start to understand the dynamics of
the neural network while it's training
but perhaps maybe maybe more interesting
for some of the users will be that it's
visual and it gives you visual feedback
which is quite rare when you're trying
to debug and design an architecture and
this is actually the kind of the kind of
visual feedback though that we're
looking to integrate into filtering a
platform if we want to make sure that
people who are using the network to
build their layers and decide how many
units that they're getting some feedback
during training so they can say earlier
okay
this layer this layer is not doing what
I expected to do I can tweak it by in
this direction so you see it's a kind of
a step around the Otto amel problem is
to give engineers more control and
feedback in the process and the final
results of the paper were that by yes by
increasing the number of hidden units in
a given layer that the saturation
decreased and that we could use the
number of training samples the number of
the tests accuracy and also the time to
Train we can use those three features
for getting feedback into what is the
optimal layer size for our deep neural
network so if so I encourage you to try
it out do pip install dev on your PI
torch model and let me know how it goes
if you get more feedback about how to
build your neural network no that's
great or if you have questions and I
would love to answer them for you thank
you
[Applause]
and the questions
okay I start with by saying that this is
a really neat presentation I actually
thought of doing maybe not something
similar but to try to optimize the
topology of the network and it kind of
inspired gave me some ideas I just
wanted to ask if I get it right
you kind of check the saturation of the
layers as you train but at the beginning
the distribution of the weights is
basically as you initialize them right
so it's sort of let's say garbage at the
beginning and after you train then you
can say something if the distribution is
right so if the saturation or cute or
not so at the beginning of the training
if I got it right you can of course
correct me if I'm wrong at the beginning
of the training you cannot get any
insight if there is under factorial over
satellite because you are kind of
mimicking the initial in size Asia right
yes
the initial initialization that that's
however you've decided it would be and
usually it's random random random
distribution so yeah that's following a
question so technically it's uh you can
get some info after you so after you are
training because if you make you kind of
brute force you just look at the test
lot and you see okay I'm getting
something something so if I change this
direction and then you see okay it's
getting worse oh I probably should have
changed the other direction but your
approach kind of gives maybe not the
magnitude but the sign if I can say of
which direction you should change to
pick your pick your lace right yes
exactly it's right it's so far
empirically if I found that if it's
between say 10 to 90 percent saturation
it's a really wide range but it's enough
that if you find that you are in that
extreme that you can correct it in the
direction in one direction so good good
point that now if I understand you that
you could be used to give more feedback
actually if you could target
specifically or give feedback to the
initialization yeah okay so one more
quick remark could you please show that
this paper you show some gonna from the
table from the paper could you show the
name of the paper maybe yeah this is in
submission right now
sure it's yeah it's under review and
I'll Prague so yeah hopefully
yeah hopefully we'll be able to see it
and show it there
Thanks be happy to send you a preprint a
few inches thank you very much for your
talk I want to ask a visor
you've worked only with dense lawyers or
you tried some different types or
convolutional lures or I don't know yes
great question so did I I did try with
convolutional layers and delve does
support convolutional layers but one
thing that's not trivial is to define
how to make generalizations about
convolutional layers so for example so
the method currently uses it makes the
some of the feature of each feature map
in the convolutional layer so and then
it tries to see how does that's that sum
or the sum or average of that how does
that change over training so yeah it's
still not exactly clear what the the
best method for that is but it does
support that so if you play with it and
find some way to improve it that would
be cool write a paper about it and you
um you've worked only with the task of
like auto encoder so it you didn't make
classification or I did also with the
CFR ten for classification and yeah that
mean it was just as useful but I think
the the images are more interesting
further out and coder to explain I I
think it's the same kind of guidelines
you get like get a range for what the
appropriate saturation is but yeah
otherwise yeah
can I also like play with a like
discover which types of convolution do I
need there are a bunch of them which
sizes and
you know you can describe you can
definitely in the code for it's a sorry
I forgot to mention that github slash
Justin shank slash dev and then there
should be documentation explaining how
the convolution works so you can there's
at least like some non implemented yet
functions so yeah if you don't want to
just take the I think the average of the
feature maps changing over time then
there's space to add another one and try
with try adding a different kind of
metric basically it's just no birth
force of different can be this topology
structures fit force of the topology
structures I'm not sure if I understand
your question in sewage you just
basically tried the all the types of
structures or or you just add law lawyer
bait lawyer yeah in this demo it was
kind of look it was a brute force kind
of to show you that how differently
layer sizes compare and in a saturation
so yeah it I think for it to be useful
application level it still requires
further fine-tuning yeah for sure okay
thank you thank you about tomorrow in
complex computation graphs where you
don't put the layer sequentially oh good
question so if you have more complex
computation graphs where you don't put
the layers sequentially then you would
probably I think you would still be able
to save the output yeah in this case
you'd still be able to save the output
of the pre activation state and the
history and then you might get some
really interesting dynamics actually
because then you get like your feedbacks
and you'd be wanting to find out if
there's some kind of I don't know
strange attractors that explain why the
patterns moving this way or another so
for the for this case that would be
really interesting to see yeah makes
publications yeah hopefully thank you
great presentation thank you
thank you
[Applause]